So we're here on Pentecost Island in Vanuatu...
...with Lindblad Expeditions, National Geographic,...
...and work the land divers.
Land diving developed in Vanuatu dating back many centuries.
While the exact reason for the diving isn't known,...
...the timing of the diving in April and May is tied to the yam harvest.
A great dive ensures a bountiful harvest.
Diving is thought to help the health and strength of the divers...
...and, of course, to show off their masculinity.
The camera's going to be up there,...
...and we hopefully going to capture it...
Probably not done before with a GoPro.
Incredible event!
They're gonna tie vines to their ankles and jump off,...
...and we're gonna hopefully capture it all.